[Music]
three two one boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Alan
Saki and we have a special guest today
Mariana saenko what's up how are you
thank you for coming on the show thank
you for having such a pleasure I'm
really excited to talk about everything
that you care about that might be a long
conversation I care about a lot of
things good yeah it's important to care
a lot of care a lot about a lot of
things especially diverse things like
you care about let's um let's do it
let's jump right into it cool so you got
a cool background masters of material
science at Carnegie Mellon and also some
biomedical engineering in there and then
ended up going off into doing some like
material science work and then and then
now venture capital work and impact
investing and so this is uh let's let's
let's start let's start off with like
start off with like how did you even
decide on what you wanted to like learn
about so I'm a I'm an immigrant myself
in a child of him as a child of
immigrants obviously and so my I was
born in Ukraine my parents came over to
the US when I was quite young and they
both have advanced degrees in
engineering and they basically made me
promise one thing which is please don't
become an engineer and so I was
hell-bent on becoming an engineer right
my mom really wanted me to be a doctor
my dad wanted me to make lots of money
and as an only child and an immigrant
child you basically handcuffed to saying
I will support you guys because you
worked your butt off to make my life
work but I think the thing that they
maybe failed in that process was that
they raised me like a daughter of
Engineers so my entire life was sitting
on trailers with my dad and him pointing
up at the cabling system and saying how
do you think that works that's awesome
that's a
good parent right I love that yeah so it
was a really fun experience growing up
just constantly having being questioned
about how the world works and why it
works that way and it wasn't that
honestly I wasn't asking a lot of those
questions my parents were asking me and
that bread and me this kind of
contextual reasoning of well wait a
second how does that thing actually work
and why and does that actually make
sense and is it efficient yeah
and so that led me to have just a
general interest and in high school I
loved I loved physics and the part of
the world that I really really didn't
understand was materials right it's this
microscopic layer interactions between
atoms crystal structures polymers and I
thought well if there's a part of the
world that I'm not going to figure out
by intuition it's this kind of
underlying structure of the universe and
I thought materials science was going to
kind of be the wave of the future and so
I ended up at Carnegie Mellon the the
intro to material science class was
really compelling they did all these fun
experiments we got to make rings out of
silver and so I was really motivated to
kind of go down that path and figure out
what the world looks like on that
subatomic scale which has been an
interesting ride yeah I love that your
dad and mom were like you can't go in
like I'm gonna go into engineering and
then because you grew up with this
fascination of like are things working
efficiently how are they working and are
they efficient how can we make them
better right can did that continuous
thought so it's almost a mmm it's almost
like seeing the world through the lens
of how things are made and how they work
and then can I figure out ways to make
them better yeah I think I always loved
that experience of not really thinking
about right there there's so much of the
world which just works and you never
think about it like you know really
think about how your refrigerator works
and then somebody actually explains it
to you and you go oh gosh that is such
an elegant design like there's such a
clever solution and I think that that's
what I get really got an
which is what are really clever
solutions because clever solutions have
all these beautiful aspects to them
right they're simple they're elegant
they're efficient and I think that
that's the way that I think about the
world and also you
you see these cobbled together solutions
where you're like God really that's the
best we could do like that all of those
moving like an internal combustion
engine is a beautiful piece of
engineering but it's also so complicated
and you think there must be a better way
to propel you know all these chunks of
mass around totally go into the
electrification yeah just some extent
right yeah so I do you think about the
world on that prospect which is you know
how can we push a design forward
thinking in engineering to make better
systems that make more sense good which
is not not a commentary that that
current systems don't work terribly well
it's that you know the march of
technology kind of keeps progressing
forward so yeah how do we push on those
boundaries yep yep that was a
long-winded answer really concise
actually on the importance of of seeing
the world and making it better okay all
right so as you're looking at this layer
because this layer is really interesting
I have a buddy of mine at Dunn at Santa
Barbara that did his PhD in
understanding what's actually going on
at the atomic level like how the coaster
sits on the table it's like and then he
studies liquids as well so how liquids
interact with each other at that level
and that is some crazy what is it like
hydro well you have like Newtonian
fluids and non-newtonian and all the
hydrodynamics therein and I mean what's
interesting is that on a macro level you
can understand how system works but the
the further and you dig the the less the
more it's magic to some extent right
because a lot of the basic principles or
the classic ways in which we define
physics and our understanding just
change and so like I spend a lot of time
studying magnetics in school I had a
phenomenal professor who kind of
shepherded me through that process
and I always did well in the classes but
my feeling was this is magic
like I have no fundamental understanding
of why this happens and why it's
consistently true but like these forces
exist and they operate in this
particular way and look we can build
solid-state memory out of it but it's
crazy kind of when you when you zoom the
perspective up and down solid-state
memory has to do with magnetism yeah so
I mean this is like a very yeah right
that it's a very very trivial point but
anytime you're reading or writing onto a
disk whether it's spinning or solid you
you basically have you're applying a
field and you're flipping bits right and
bits just have to do with they aligned
in one direction under one field and
then you take the field and you take the
field away and they stay aligned and
that's how you write a zero or one and
so in spinning disks you you do that by
like actually spinning you know a
physical piece of material in solid
state it's a slightly different
mechanism but a lot of the basic
principles of like how do you do
permanent memory storage whether it's on
tape or on a driver some other it has to
do with how you align magnetic fields in
grain boundaries in materials so we
don't know about our world and the
brains just not able to compute even
half a percent of everything alright so
okay now with your specific work in
material science where were you diving
and immediately afterward after school
like oh my own work was was really weird
and somewhat convoluted and I was just
so fortunate that that Carnegie Mellon
was a great school that afforded you
whatever opportunity you sought out to
some extent so I was working on these
things called potato magnetites
which is a class of magnetic materials
that are pretty prevalent
on exoplanets so on Mars
and doing some interesting research
about how those materials are created
what are their properties are they
potentially valuable for applications
bless you thank you on earth that
weirdly led me to get involved with
something called the Google Lunar XPrize
because Carnivale has a amazing robotics
division and at the time there was a
team that was basically trying to put
more or less a tractor on the moon to
put it like it was a rover and it was a
robot but there's particular visions and
that team and I got really inspired by
that idea so I ended up doing kind of
taking my own interest and excitement
about materials on other planets and
saying well actually maybe the more
interesting question is how do you get
to those materials and how do you test
them so I got really inspired by this
idea of robots on Mars and robots on the
moon and that drove me down a path of a
ton of a systems and control systems and
worrying about how we're going to go put
interesting research in really dynamic
caustic challenging environments without
putting people at risk and at harm
mmm-hmm and so that's kind of slowly
made this transition not necessarily
away from material science but my
interests in in materials and where
materials originated from led to me
thinking about well how do we actually
get to those places and we'll say I
wanted to get out of lab yeah that's
like right you breathe a lot of
chemicals in a lot of these labs whether
they're wet chemistry labs or material
science labs and you started thinking
man if I ever have children they're
gonna have tails because of all the
chemicals I've been breathing in so I
think I think my own my own passions and
my own desire to like the outside and
collect a little bit more vitamin D made
me want to get out of lab and a little
bit more into field work yeah so then
it was wondering how materials would
interact on exoplanets yeah I mean an
event of the transition to robotics yeah
I think those would be on exoplanets
yeah if I if I look in in hindsight I
could I could draw that line in reality
I was inside a pinball machine right
because that's that's what life is in
you know in your early 20s where you're
curious excited about a lot of things
have no idea which one of those you know
will prove fruitful and honestly I
remember experiencing a lot of jealousy
around people who had this single-minded
passion in a particular area right I had
had friends who were studying math and
maybe even a particular subset of math
and it was just obvious that they were
gonna go on to phd's and be very
successful and they were so
single-mindedly excited about a
particular field of study and I was
never like that I was always near me to
write like a mile wide and cello was a
baking pan and all of them so I'd love
to say that I studied material science
and biomedical engineering and those two
things tied together to robotic but the
reality is I was like a squirrel and
every time I saw a shiny object that I
thought was interesting that was the
direction that I turned which I've been
fortunate enough that that's worked out
in my favor yeah I wish I could be a
true polymath in terms of having that
level of technical competency across
those spaces but certainly in terms of
overall excitement and interest yeah so
then okay so then the work in autonomous
starts and then robotic starts okay so
tell us about this so so this is kind of
a funny thing so I was finishing up
school around 2010 so eight years ago
and this was right after the DARPA Grand
Challenge
grants where it went from you know a
handful of university students across
some of the top universities saying
let's just build a driverless car you
know we're not a lot of vision about you
know why and it certainly wasn't I don't
think anybody in their head said you
know this is the spawn of the future
driverless car market that hopefully
will exist it was people trying to solve
a really really hard problem because
they were excited about it and for me I
thought that this was really interesting
because I'm a little bit of a Motorhead
like I love cars I love motorcycles I
love things that go fast and have the
chance of hurting you and the things
that I realized is that I love those
things because they're fun but mobility
in terms of actual commuting is terrible
and dangerous and the reason it's so
dangerous because nobody's paying
attention because it's not fun and so I
believe in human out of the loop
autonomy in the sense that humans are
really really bad at competitive
consistent repetitive tasks like we
stopped paying attention entirely right
I mean how many times have you driven
somewhere and been like how did I get
here totally totally ready we go on
autopilot and when humans are on
autopilot it's terrible mm-hm and the
more I learned about robotics and
robotic control systems and consistent
closed-loop controls with feedback
mechanisms I was like that's a much
better way to control a system that is
doing essentially the same thing with a
handful of corner cases and so for me it
wasn't in Congress about this idea of
wanting driverless cars to exist and
also still loving motorcycles because I
thought you know humans should spend
more time doing things that are fun that
they're actually present to mm-hmm and
less time doing terrible dangerous
things that they don't even want to be
present to because nobody's paying
attention when they're sitting in
traffic yeah and so I for me it was such
a natural flip like when I saw that
transition happening and the technology
maturing and you know a bunch of college
and graduate students actually being
able to build a car that drove around a
city block autonomously I was like oh
this is the future
and this was at a time where everyone's
like this is never gonna happen people
want to own cars this is when car
companies were still saying will never
go autonomous because we care about the
drive experience right and now they're
all mobility companies so for me that
flip was so obvious and I thought about
it across all contexts right from
aviation which already has a lot of
autopilot - cars - in general like what
are tasks that we're doing as people
because we're used to it but where
technology has actually caught up and
can kind of take over the wheel I like
how you're very adamant about human
being out of the loop because we don't
really pay that much attention to the
process and not only is that true that
we're not paying that much attention to
the process but then we have emotion and
sleep deprivation and sometimes they're
intoxicated we're trying to eat we're
trying to do this in the car all these
different things and what better way
than to take the human completely out of
the loop hopefully completely soon that
will actually get to that point and then
if you want to drive then you're you'll
have to pay more your insurance or
something laughs and your insurance and
yeah okay so human out of the loop and
the being with the actual DARPA
challenge yeah yeah I say I got to know
the team at Carnegie Mellon that was
working on it a lot of that team was
working on the Google Lunar XPrize that
I was more directly involved with and so
I can't take credit for really any of
the phenomenal advances but I was
definitely hanging around that group of
people and and continue to be inspired
by them and then where does where do you
go after that
then I make it out here yeah right it
will happen it's a good question
I had the good fortune of joining a
start-up early right out of school
a lot of the challenges we kind of
talked about the entrepreneurs dream and
trials and so it was a great deal of fun
being in an early engineer at a very
very early company we struggled from a
lot of things which i think as a as a VC
these days I maybe have more compassion
and empathy than I would otherwise if I
hadn't been through that experience but
it was it was a challenging it was a
challenging place and it was challenging
because we didn't quite know how to fund
it or how to build a meaningful business
that was self-sustaining and I think if
you actually want to build technology
that's viable the business case has to
close like you can't just keep kind of
pouring gasoline and into bad ideas and
hoping that they eventually become
economically viable right true
sustainability has to by nature be
economically viable and that wasn't
necessarily the case
in some of the early projects that I was
involved with and so I ended up as a as
a research engineer and a larger
materials company and had this had this
kind of consistent feeling that there
was a translation layer that was missing
between technical people who are trying
to build interesting project projects
and the strategy people who I never
quite understood what they were doing
but every time they came and talked to
us I was like you guys actually don't
know what's going on in these labs and
it's not because you're not intelligent
people it's because you're just not
spending enough time on the ground floor
and I started thinking about well who
are these consultants who come in and
tell us how we should run our businesses
and who are these strategy and MBAs who
kind of you know show up and tell you
what research you should be focused on
and how these markets work because my
experience on the kind of build side of
that was I'm not sure you guys know what
you're talking about right because the
like that's not the timeline we operated
on that's not how much this is gonna
cost and also like have you actually
validated that anybody wants this stupid
thing we're trying to build and so I
thought about it for a while
and ended up at a place called Lux
Research which was just a phenomenal
education in the sense that I was became
a market analyst and a consultant and it
was like somebody paying me to get an
MBA essentially and I had the good
fortune of working with incredible
clients they're like you know Tier one
automotive suppliers Oh II am so
original equipment manufacturers two
large chemical materials companies
pharma companies and all of them have
these questions which is like what is
the future of robotics what is the
future of autonomy how does these things
except our you know change our business
practices how do our own divisions have
to change what a cool job yeah it was a
super-fun job it was an amazing job the
challenge is you never you you've got to
make a lot of recommendations and travel
a bunch and speak I mean it was it was
an enormous amount of fun the problem
was that if you're an opinionated and
obsessive person like I am it's really
really challenging to kind of pour your
heart into some work product and then
hand it over to somebody and watch them
read it and basically ignore it or throw
it in the trash or say like you know pat
you on the head say thank you so much
for doing this and we're going in a
totally different direction and I
realized that I was so passionate about
some of the things that we were doing
and a lot of our focus was looking at
how early very very early startups we're
going to disrupt these large industries
and I thought that you know somebody who
lives in this translation layer should
make sure that these startups are
getting funded because you know these
big companies are going to continue
ignoring them they're just gonna kick
their butts and so that's basically how
I fell into venture capital what were
some of the small companies that were
coming up and that we're dealing with
larger equipment manufacturers um let me
think about it so so I obviously can't
share names but a great example is I
remember a company one of my clients
called me and said hey I heard about
these guys Cruz Automation can you just
go like call them and see what's up and
so I
I got on the phone and I talked to a
couple of people at cruz kyle boy
included and you know at the time when i
spoke to them they were retrofitting
cars with autonomy and they couldn't get
into the drive-by-wire system so they
were literally putting actuators under
the pedals and I asked them like how do
you train this in the rain and I think
they more or less answered well it's
Southern California so it doesn't rain
that much so we don't you know it was it
was very much like scrappy early startup
you thought these guys were crazy if you
trained in the school of kind of
robotics that I did you were you looked
at them and said you guys are reckless
however I I remember writing this and
kind of my write-up afterwards I was
like these guys are nuts they're a
little bit reckless but I also think
they're brilliant and that you really
should pay attention particularly
because the leadership staff here is
just somewhat mindlessly passionate
about this space so I would not discount
them and to they've pulled enough really
clever team like team members together
that you guys need to either pay
attention very very early and maybe be a
little bit worried right fast forward I
think not even five years later they
were acquired for like the better part
of a billion dollars by GM boom and I
can share that Jam was not the company
that called me asking about them yeah
and the company that had called asking
me about them was like kind of read my
report and were like ah you know not
nothing to pay attention to and then
proceeded to scramble after the fact to
try to catch up in a lot of times
anyways and so I think there were a lot
of experiences like that where totally
they kind of called and either said you
know what have you seen that's
interesting and you respond and say well
oh you care about collaborative robots
well there's actually like a bunch of
these companies out there and they're
doing really interesting work and
whether it's rethink robotics or
Universal or any of these others and a
lot of them said
too small of a market not going to
affect our bottom line not a problem
and they might have often been right but
you know if you zoom out to a long
enough time scale if they if they had
acted at the point in which they
originally cared they'd be way better
off I wonder how many of these examples
exist especially here in Silicon Valley
of people analyzing companies and seeing
like they're still really small they're
little a little scrappy they're they're
passionate but they are not really
putting the right things together yet
and then you like pass along these
reports and people look at them and then
they're just like holy [ __ ] they blew up
a couple months or a year or whatever
later so it seems to be that
electrification is now becoming a huge
China rolled out like 15,000 buses in
Shenzhen that are all-electric and
they've like 50 electric car companies
so that's some big progress for them I
mean versus us where I don't even know
City any cities that have only electric
buses
I don't off the top of my head either
although that's that's probably just a
lack of education or on my part I'm
certain that we we are making pushers in
those spaces you know I think it's been
hard for the car companies for a long
time just because if you look you know
so what like 100 million new cars a year
worldwide a hundred thousand of which
are Tesla's or electric cars as a whole
so right that the overall percentage of
electric vehicles sold to vehicles so
this is so minuscule little small that
you think and these guys have the
production lines and the capability and
the capacity that you think will you
know when when the market shows true
interest then the cars will show up the
prime electrification is fundamentally a
challenging conversation to have because
there's two axes on which to consider it
first is the overall lifetime cost of
the vehicle which you could argue from a
maintenance perspective with an electric
vehicle it's just a much simpler right a
motor is more simple is
simpler than an engine hybrids are weird
because it's actually like the worst of
both worlds in terms of needing to care
for both systems but pure electric
versus pure combustion the flipside is
that if you're just trying to calculate
your like net co2 carbon output you're
not necessarily better off with an
electric vehicle right so if you it
really depends on where you like tricity
comes from so if you buy an electric car
in New York where a lot of the
electricity is still powered by pretty I
should be careful about naming States
because I don't know these numbers off
the top of my head but I have seen
graphs that basically do a kind of
global reports of where does your raw
raw electricity come from right is a
coal powered is it water hydroelectric
whatever and that totally changes the
equation right so in California you're
actually pretty well-off because most of
our electricity is reasonably clean but
there's massive swath of the world where
you're not doing the world any great
good other than putting yourself on the
back for driving an electric car and
that's one of the challenges was just
it's not about what you do so much as
what do you do on a grid level scale
yeah so plugging in your car and in
getting electrical power from fossil
fuels pretty terrible pretty terrible
versus just filling up the car with
gasoline that's a combustion engine and
driving that it's actually more
efficient it is actually more efficient
well it's more so efficient is a weird
word it is cleaner in the sense of
greenhouse gas emissions it's cleaner
interesting okay now how about how about
when the car is being is using solar or
wind for its energy for electric power
okay so that's clean energy then what
about the cost of replacing the battery
what do we do with the battery afterward
yeah yeah right these are these are big
questions
especially second-life batteries for
automotive right so we start producing
all these car batteries batteries are
still only so good and they're not
really as good as we'd like them to be
and once you you can't realistically
drive a car once the battery has gone
through a lot of deep discharges because
it just loses efficiency right and so
you need to replace your battery far
more often then you think you would
mostly because it it's efficient she
drops off so much once it's gone through
a lot of cycles particularly if they're
really deep discharges and this just has
to do with the chemistry so people are
trying to make the chemistry better on
the reusable side people I've seen
business plans for people who are trying
to you know take these batteries out of
cars and use them for second life to
like put them on robots so there are
little mobile charging stations because
who cares if that battery's a little
less efficient I think we'll see what
happens
to some extent it's a chicken-and-egg
problem that there's not that many
electric cars on the road or vehicles as
electric vehicles as a whole on the road
so what to do with the second life
batteries isn't that big of a problem
but it's it's kind of like the nuclear
energy problem right like we worry about
nuclear waste from nuclear energy plants
and what on earth were gonna do with it
but only out of scale when those plants
actually show up a little distributed
and so I think people are worrying about
it and starting to think about it
there's not that much of a market for it
today nor is that that much supply just
don't want them to go into landfills
that's right and I think that I would
love to see more projects about you know
butter recyclability and reuse and
economically viable reuse because it's
one of these things if you're putting
more energy in to get these betters out
and use them for some other use case
like I don't know maybe you're better
off just storing them until we figure
out how to recycle them yeah yeah that's
that's one thing that I've always been
thinking about now with electrification
is know okay all good so okay so with
electrification I'm thinking a lot about
like the cost of actually the recycling
of the battery and of where the energy
comes from and this is all really
important and then I'm wondering about
like what's gonna be the next step after
that and I think that maybe
understanding nuclear fusion is a really
interesting step after that I would
really like to figure out how to fuse
atoms and and get more energy out of it
than we put into it and then be able to
power things with that that sounds so
appetizing and so abundant and then will
will be good forever but and this kind
of gets us into a little bit of the
quantum world that you're interested in
as well so maybe tell us about your
interest in quantum computing quantum
mechanics cuz that's where we met we met
at a cool yeah we met at dinner party
about quantum computing because that
Sanford's is gonna nutshell for ya what
are you doing I'm Thursday night is
quantum computing dinner it's this is a
ridiculous place to live and lovely
furring a lot of reason whoo like I
totally love it and and a shout out to
our good friends at UC who do put on
these lovely dinner parties right I mean
my interest in in quantum computing is
is trivial to some extent which is that
you know Moore's law we've been doubling
the number of transistors and reducing
the cost of computing the better part of
the last 50 years and quantum computing
is hopefully the next step in that
process and nobody really knows what
that transition looks like right we want
CPUs GPUs now we're talking about TP use
then there's GPU tensor tensor
processing units Google's printing
papers answer flow yeah those deep
learning right and so the idea is are
there chips that are uniquely or are
there architectures frameworks
that are particularly well suited to
doing some level neural net computation
whether it's better matrix multiply or
some fundamental approach to to making
to making some of these hard problems
honestly just faster to solve and to
converge on solutions and that is kind
of the promise of quantum computing
right is that you Kewpie use right q is
there any this I don't know there's some
space between GPUs some massive future
computing and then QP use and the beauty
of QP use is that theoretically you you
can solve all sorts of challenging
optimization problems by it you know
doing a lot of hard work and translating
them into a forum that a quantum competi
quantum algorithm can you know take to
the quantum processing unit and arrive
much faster at the lowest energy
solution because the electrons will
tunnel their way and and land at the the
most likely solution set of the problem
space there's a lot of challenges with
that rate which is like how do you
actually qualify that you're in the
actual true solution and not trapped in
some local minimum or a maximum I think
I should back up yes but so I think the
short answer is I care a lot about
quantum computing in the simple reason
that it's it's the next transition of
faster better computing and every time
we get faster better computing people
push a lot of interesting things forward
and there's like 10 billion in yeah and
people are pummeling like stupid amounts
of money into this right it's really
important right dfj invested in a
quantum annealing system more than a
decade ago which I don't even think we
said that you were at Airbus yes ago and
now right so I started I kind of fell
into venture capital as an investment
partner at Airbus focused on aerospace
aviation robotics deep space Airbus is
these massive they're a380s that are
flying around
right yeah what's like how many people
like a thousand people and up in a plane
like 800 so I'm like a lot of people a
lot of people together it's the ones you
yeah it's the ones that you like
internationally double-deckers yeah yeah
they're beautiful and then they have
like those great rolls-royce engines
that are just insanely powerful and
they're just like the great aircraft
they're just made really well and we're
really blessed to be able to fly around
internationally and those and so they're
venture arm I will get back to quantum
computing don't you worry
let's go down the let's go down the
Airbus managers one quick what was there
what was there what was their shtick
like they're I mean they're like like
Dubai or like Emirates like bought a
bunch of air buses like the most in the
world they have like like 500 Airbus's
versus like the other Airlines only have
like a hundred or something or I mean I
don't know the the finer points of these
contracts but what do you mean what was
their strength well stir stick with cuz
I'm the French yeah and the German and
Spanish and Spanish and British
interesting so but Airbus is based in
France
it's a multinational corporation it's
headquartered in Toulouse France but it
there are Central European governments
that have controlling shares and so
where'd they manufacture so it's a mix
so large portions of the aircraft are
made in Germany parts are made in the UK
there's big manufacturing lines in Spain
final assembly so the final assembly
line the foul is in Toulouse
there's also Airbus America's which has
manufacturing in like Alabama I want to
go to the FAL yeah it's probably a
massive hangar yeah there's a bunch of
them and so you walk in and you see
these I mean you see full aircraft being
assembled on the wings being pressed
fitted in yeah
they're massive all that'd be so cool to
go check that out I have to go with
okay so then they're making like you
know they're making some these are the
international planes of today like there
are them there right so JetBlue flies
primarily right so yeah so there's a320
is like one of the most common aircraft
that you'll fly on today and that's like
a 300 400 500 yeah you know when you get
any or like to you know single-aisle
aircraft two to three seats on each side
right so I would say that you know
Boeing and Airbus are your two major
aircraft manufacturers there's a couple
others out there but for every Boeing
aircraft there's kind of an Airbus
equivalent and vice versa
okay so Airbus's actually has a couple
different yeah it's got the full stream
of course not but also remember Airbus
is a much bigger company than commercial
aircraft is I think the the kind of
brand name of Airbus but there's also
Airbus defensive space which is a
massive defense organization do that as
well
yeah and then there's they don't make
fighter jets all right they do yeah the
Eurofighter they make a Eurofighter yeah
it's a really cool aircraft and a bunch
of mil and then there's Airbus
helicopters which is one of the largest
helicopter manufacturers ever then they
sell a lot of helicopters as well yeah
so a mix of military and non-defense
it's crazy
okay so we're you were just out of VTOL
tall being vertical takeoff and landing
yeah that's exciting I want to see if we
can touch on that maybe along the way
but well maybe let's do it now and then
we'll talk about the Airbus investing
then we'll get back to quantum computing
but what's the like what's the future of
VTOL it seems like it seems like that
Elon is digging holes in the ground and
it's like it kind of makes sense right
but at the same time you know you don't
want like they're saying like you don't
want a hub cap to fall off and just like
chop someone's head off so and there's
like obviously all the complexities of
the plane above us versus below us so
what are your thoughts are on the
yeah so so Ilana has the boring company
literally digging tunnels that will pull
a vacuum and then we'll have ultra-fast
rail through there but they're pretty
fixed paths right it's it's basically a
really really fast train underground and
we have on land we have you know
electric scooters and bicycles and cars
and light rail and trains and heavy rail
and ships and containers so we have like
this whole spectrum of mobility and then
we have aircraft right and generally
aircraft like what is the shortest
flight you're reasonably gonna take
probably an hour yeah like here to LA
couple hundred miles but the challenge
is that we sit in traffic all day long
like I live in Mountain View and we're
in San Francisco right now and so if
there's no traffic probably takes me 45
minutes in traffic like give me two
hours it can be a disaster they get here
but what if there was a business case in
which somebody said I can always get you
from San Jose to San Francisco in 20
minutes like how do you do that
well you could dig a really really big
hole and pour in a ton of money into
infrastructure or you could fly short
haul planes where you just need landing
zones and you know how hard is that and
so I think the the excitement of the
VTOL market and I would say that there's
more hype than reality and more money
than sense in the market to some extent
is people saying wait a second we know
how to do autopilot we know how to make
aircraft reasonably cheaply and we know
how to do light aircraft that are
electric that can fly these medium sized
routes so is there a market for
consistently flying between places like
San Jose to San Francisco or through
downtown LA or through Jakarta or Mexico
City or any of these basically densely
packed urban areas there's challenges in
that space which is you know aircraft
are loud people are really afraid of
them they are afraid of them I mean you
know I think a lot of people have like a
very visceral
reaction to getting into a fully auto
piloted aircraft and also like we don't
really know certify that helicopters are
allowed that's for sure really loud but
but at the same time maybe adding four
propellers instead of one might quiet it
to quiet it down a little I don't I
don't know yeah so I think that
companies like Joby aviation which
recently raised a large round of funding
for kind of its new you know they're
flying a full-scale prototype and
they've done a lot of work to make their
vehicle reasonably quiet
I think I'm saving is huge like you said
right so it's this caught is this it's
always a calculation right and it's the
calculation of cost convenience time
right and everyone is willing to make
different sliding levers do you think
that's gonna go towards a veto or boring
underground or above-ground I I think if
you can do autonomy I think if you if
you can find a path to have certifiable
autonomy for aircraft I think it takes
less infrastructure and build out to
rapidly scale to a lot of VTOL aircraft
you can dig a lot of holes totally that
said I think there are areas which
consistently have bad wind or tons of
rain or poor visibility or you just need
to translate like in LA boring might be
way better because maybe there's just a
lot more people who are always traveling
it's about like population density and
consistency over Allen right yeah so if
you can have the efficiency of like a
ton of people need to get from A to B
mhm
dig a hole but if you want a
multi-faceted layer more I guess freedom
of route choice then maybe the aircraft
I don't know that it's one or the other
yeah yeah totally both could live at the
same time exactly in different use cases
that are better I just I always I always
wonder the what what we what are we
building today that's going to be
archaic tomorrow or in a year or
whatever is a great question because
like why are we wasting our time
building these things for these
short-term gains that are right yeah I
just want to say I just want to add you
know tell a transportation is the way to
go
you know as soon as we fix the whole fly
thing you know we're rolling I don't
even know why you guys are talking about
this you know the Hyperloop or the
vertical takeoff and landing fascinating
but you know let's get on the
teletransportation conversation and that
yeah there you go I'm sure you don't I'm
sure you're not a big thinker yeah I
know you're only limited nobody I
actually think about that question a lot
and for me the space that I've landed
that that I've had a fundamental shift
about that is food and specifically what
we eat and how we make what we eat like
I mentally believe them 20 years we're
gonna look back at the meat industry and
go are you serious
we grew those poor animals in those
conditions in such an inefficient system
and ate them and packaged and grocery
stores and we're happy with that like
that's crazy yeah totally I hope we do I
hope we hope we get there even faster so
okay so we mean we're segue into future
food and I still want to do at least a
bit on quantum computing maybe we do
food since we're already here on the
food on the food side of things besides
looking back and being like holy [ __ ] I
was so archaic the way that we consume
grew and consumed animals what else are
you most looking forward to with the
future of food I think I'm looking
forward to I think
one like malnutrition on a global scale
is one of the it's a primary driving
factor in terms of if you look in
people's ability to withstand disease
and pathogens and challenges like in
Africa like you know the the better
access to consistent nutrition that
people have the more likelihood they
have of surviving any number of
challenges that are thrown their way and
so I think that while it's challenging
obviously to solve global hunger we are
moving into a state where earth is
changing temperatures are rising
agriculture is changing and so I think a
lot about how do we continue feeding the
Earth's growing population in a
consistent manner addressing
malnutrition and how does science and
cell cultivation and better growth
practices enable us to grow better food
and I think this is one of the
challenges right like if you worried
Michael Pollan's books who basically
says that like you know people cook at
home for our healthier meals than
corporations cook for them yeah as a
venture capitalist who invests in
companies startups that hopefully
eventually are very successful and
become corporations like how can we flip
that script how can we think about how
do corporations
grow and make food that doesn't suck yep
and so I think a lot about that and and
I get really excited about you know what
are what are the way is that whether
it's artificial intelligence machine
learning better cell cultivation that
helps us make our food more reasonable
and hopefully cheaper and more
accessible without just throwing away
all the nutrition right because right
now like the reason that food is
terrible is because sugar and fat and
corn syrup are really cheap so how do we
you make cheap nutritional food yeah
yeah hopefully planting large fields of
spinach and blueberries and having
robots harvest them and ship them off to
us maybe or vertical farming or you know
growing meat and more of a cell
cultivation
situation that it's more efficient I
think yep
I think there's a lot of avenues that
are that I'm keen to explore yeah yeah
because food is something that we do
three times a day across the world and
malnutrition is something we've talked
about on the show before as well
people's brains don't have the the right
energy for being able to have
neurogenesis or even just compute their
environments and make good decisions and
get enough of the nutrients for their
growth especially when they're being
raised into the world so that's a big
deal I'm still a billion people in the
world have some sort of malnutrition
it's not more yeah sure it's more than a
billion what a lot of dumb people Marcus
no you know I'm one of them though so
you saying a billion come on right down
the middle I don't know if it's exactly
that high it's it's a lot and so is
access to clean water as well it's a
very high around a billion as well I
think it is a billion to on food and
then 800 million on clean water it's
something like that so so yeah good good
on future food there's yeah there's uh
there's there's a lot to do in that in
that sector and it's too bad that high
fructose corn syrup and fat and sugar
and all the [ __ ] is just so salt it's
just also you totally do cook better
food for yourself at home
yeah we're hosting Michael Pollan oh yes
on the 6th of June oh sure to that yeah
so he's he is very lovely we'll be at
the Mission Bay conference center sold
out it's fun
so okay now let's let's let's see if we
can do the Cliff Notes version of this
and you teach me along the way I'll see
if I can do this so okay so initial
computation is
is the is the elect is the electricity
flowing through the transistor that says
one or zero that goes on or off how does
that first part work that's the CPU in a
classical in a classical yeah I don't
know that we want to like spend the last
ten minutes of our time together going
look I think the the basic thing to
consider is in computation you have
energy coming in from like a wall right
and pumping into some compute system you
know that is trying to solve a problem
set yo now one of the challenges is that
a lot of classically hard problems like
Monte Carlo simulations optimizations
they don't they're difficult to
translate into a computer architecture
that can crunch through it very quickly
right this is actually why encryption
works something encryption is all that
foolproof it just takes so much energy
to potentially brute force break an
encryption that it's not computationally
worthwhile right it's too costly to
break RSA encryption today and so what
you think about with quantum computers
is is there a class of problems that
when translated to a quantum computing
system are much more efficient to solve
right so can you now suddenly run these
algorithms in parallel can you break up
the problem in a way that the natural
architecture of the quantum computer
solves the problem much faster with less
computational cost so energy comes from
the wall how do you solve the
computational problem as quickly as
possible that's right and then
normal computer architecture just is
like two-dimensional and then yeah so
most of it's like matrix multiply today
and often the question is you know are
you running are you running it in kind
of a classical metric can you paralyze
these problem sets parallel lies so have
different course computing that's right
right and can you you know can you
basically spin up more and more cores
and can they do can they can they break
up the problem in a way that when you
actually parallelize the problem it is
more
because there's some there's some
problems like that's not official that's
not that efficient or or solving an in
parallel doesn't get you that much
further down the path and how is quantum
different than parallel computing
computations breaking it up into
parallel so so quantum computing is it's
just it's mirrored and you should have
some right you should get will to come
on and walk you through the the
technical bits and there are different
ways to do it right so there's quantum
annealing systems there's full quantum
systems and each of them are suited to a
class of problems but but just the
cliffnotes and that you form the wall is
that there is a way that you could
construct a problem in terms of
translating it into a quantum algorithm
that a quantum computer process
basically says I can adjust this
algorithm the data you've given it to me
and I can spit out the lowest energy
solution and that kind of like tunnels
through what is otherwise a massive
brute force calculation ok ok that's
still super super super service level
very difficult to even you know get what
is going on in there but so it's a
translation into a quantum algorithm in
a quantum process and then that can
tunnel through faster than can just
separate on a bunch of cores and try
that ok all right so the this is for
future conversation with you know with
will Zhang or other people from Righetti
or d-wave and all these different
companies that hopefully will feature on
the show will talk whole episode on
quantum computing but thanks for the
surface level ok run you through a quick
a couple of these simulation gamuts that
we usually ask I'm gonna smash these two
questions together they have to do with
in wealth inequality and globalization
so how do we figure out how to work
together through across all the borders
around the world as well as how do we
figure out how to really help move
everybody forward no matter what
socioeconomic status they're on yeah not
a trivial question I think for me it's
on on three fronts I think if you enable
better cheaper safer more efficient
mobility for people that drives upward
socio-economic
because right now people live in
expensive city centers and rich people
live there and that's like a lot of the
driver of urbanization and poorer people
move further and further out because
they get displaced but the jobs are
still centrally located right so they're
their lives get skewed and so the more
that you can enable people to live in
the style that they prefer and that best
suits them and enable better mobility I
think that drives a lot of opportunity
yeah I think access to basic basic
resources in terms of nutritional food
and water to the point of you know that
improves cognition and I think you have
to start with basically better access to
nutritional food in schools yeah and I
think the third bit is actually and I
think this this stems from the fact that
I come from Eastern Europe and there's
like a whole class of questions around
governance and social freedom and can
you believe I ever mentor not I do I
think we are moving into a world because
of the internet and social media where
we exist in digital tribes and those
kind of live beyond our government
borders and I think that that is
actually pushing a lot of good things
forward in the world right because if
you live in a very socially constrained
environment and you feel very alone
because you're gay or because you don't
fit in the constraints of whatever
society you exist in but you can have
access to social media and you know
whatever your digital community is that
gives that empowers you as an individual
to act in your systems and kind of push
those boundaries and I think it is
creating I hope more if not peaceful
accepting and compassionate world and I
think we see that in each subsequent
generation because the more we're
exposed to our differences the more
tolerant we are of them I hope so
right so the short is mobility food and
kind of digital connections to get us
out of our rabbit holes
those are really good okay I don't know
I think so I think you know things I
worry about yeah or at least I try to
find ways to protect and make better
yeah no this is especially bringing
people closer to information highways
getting them access and getting them
closer and also just location
agnosticism will be great in the future
because right now so many people will
spend their time in commutes and exactly
like I think everybody freaks out about
this future of robots and and will
autonomy take over our lives and our
jobs and our capabilities and like the
one thing humans are actually good at is
adaptation and maybe that's the only
thing we should focus on in terms of
education and you know building up our
next generation of leaders is like how
do you adapt to a rapidly changing
environment because that's the only
thing humans are particularly good at
training at and consistently iterating
on because that's what's amazing right
like that's the amazing thing about
technology is used you like unleash the
Internet and nobody knows what why it's
useful at first and then all these
people kind of create these beautiful
platforms on top of it like your show
and that's where the value stems from
it's not because anybody was
prescriptive about it because you
adapted to a platform that otherwise
didn't exist and you created value out
of it yeah and like we say on the show
Allah we talked about the importance of
taking content away from what we're
saying right now and actually creating
with it making some sort of further
impact with it right so do you think
we're alone in the cosmos you know this
is an interesting question and I I think
about it on a couple aspects which is I
I think so much of our feeling alone is
about our in like in general are our
feelings around loneliness or about like
a lack of communication right and so
we're not great at communicating with
each other as people like you and I have
great rapport and it's lovely to chat
with you
and you know I feel less alone because I
have a fiance who I feel like
understands me and we have great
connection and I feel not alone when I'm
out in nature because I feel a level of
connection and interface when I'm either
mountain biking or skiing where I feel
like it does feel like a conversation
right it's on a different context and so
the way that I think about whether or
not we're alone is I don't think we're
alone but I'm not sure if we carry the
capacity currently to exchange in a
meaningful way with larger and larger
sense systems that that might have forms
of communication but maybe exist on
waveforms or timelines or perspectives
that will we lack the capacity right
like do weather systems communicate do
planets communicate do stars it's easy
to say no because that's an easier and a
trivial answer but it's more interesting
to think about like well flowers give
pollen to bees is that a form of
communication and so yeah I don't know
that I think about like aliens on other
planets because that that feels like
such a that feels like such a
in-your-face construct that's very much
presented by Hollywood and I think more
about like you know what is a time line
or a time scale or like a magnitude of
cosmos of I guess cognition or you know
is like does the universe have
consciousness as a universe as a planet
as a subsystem and you think yeah you
know I think of it I have no data to the
negative and I have some potential of
data towards the positive right that the
like you you could potentially
extrapolate how these are forms of
consciousness and conversation and
mission do you think that we're in a
computer simulation I think it's a
really interesting question to consider
particularly from from the question of
like if we were in a computer simulation
do we have the technology to sample the
time rate of that simulation to ever
recognize that we're in one right cuz
that looks like a yeah a basic question
which is even if we were in a simulation
could could we recognize it or is the
timestamp of the simulation half
painting on a pace that's faster than so
I think even if we're in a computer
simulation like that's fine I like I
enjoy this reality it's a great deal of
fun it's pretty good its tactical I can
move things around in it and so I'm not
sure it matters I think there are ways
to interpret simulation theory that make
it matter
definitely for another show then I would
love to have that to be with you good
well then what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world god there's
so many beautiful things in the world I
you know i I've never been a person
that's all that geared towards lists or
but I think that the most beautiful
feeling of the world is that moment that
everybody hopefully experiences of like
true elation where like whatever it is
and it's usually something that's like
very fleeting but that sense of joy that
just kind of shows up because like you
decided to show up
and be present and actually notice
something that's great and I think that
the thing that I find really beautiful
about that is there's no barrier to
experiencing that right like you don't
have to look a particular way or have a
certain amount of money or whatever it's
like that sense of being present and
noticing what's around you that for me
is the most beautiful thing yeah I love
how it's democratized across everyone
it's just that feeling right it's like
that childlike sense of
wonder and I think the thing that is
really inspiring is to look at somebody
who looks nothing like you has a
completely different background that you
probably speak no words in common with
and you can see that emotion on their
face right because it's like in their
eyes and then the way they carry
themselves and it's these fleeting
moments and that is like true connection
you rock
thank you so much for coming on the show
thank you we greatly appreciate you we
look forward to more great conversations
together that would be fun yeah thank
you everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it
sorry for all the tangents the we had a
good amount of tangents but we came back
to almost everything quite well I'm very
very impressed it was good good
conversation good dialogue
you're very Polymathic which is good
there too where all the tangents come
from that's and it's a it's good to keep
up it feels good you know my brains
activated no we didn't start with enough
coffee did everyone thank you so much
for tuning in if you had a good time
definitely give a comment below with
your thoughts subscribe join the family
give the share talk to other people
about it go write about it go make a
video about it maybe start a project in
one of these fields so go create with
the content also join us on patreon so
we can continue supporting the studio so
we can continue growing the endeavour
impacting more people you get access to
VIP seating get access to exclusive
content and get access to join the
production with us so we'd love to have
you join us and thank you Ron Vargas our
producing partner greatly appreciate it
and we'll see you guys soon thank you
[Music]
[Music]